I would start by changing our whole
system of revenue to a fair tax our
system our income tax system is corrupt
the Congress raids the income tax
surplus and has been spending it on
day-to-day operation we need something a
little more fundamental than that you
judge a civilization by how they take
care of their elderly how they take care
of their youth and how they take care of
their veterans and the United States of
America fails on all three counts shame
on us we can do better but when we're
controlled by the military-industrial
complex that controls our government
lock stock and barrel you get what
you're getting right now which is
horrific follow the money if you want to
see which way the government is going to
go in the future I'm accused of having
not much money my god this is a I wear
this is a badge of courage that i
haven't sold out and don't intend to
sell out people contribute to my
campaign I don't have time to go through
the list and see who it is other people
may do that but I you're not going to
get one thing by contributing to my
campaign good government honest
government with integrity and we're
going to turn this country around I'll
be one of the great presidents of the
United States and I won't be owned by
wall street or the military-industrial
complex or the medical industrial
complex or the war industrial complex
and of course not talk about the war on
drugs which is which is a tragedy it's
the scourge of our inner cities and
everybody knows it's a failure but
nobody is providing the leadership to
end it we had FDR who ended prohibition
well I'm going to end the war on drugs I
become president of the United States
count on that
you